question allait maxime ta meilleure amie
dans tpm pc agathe ou kelly à ça je
savais qu'on aime poser des questions de
façon je savais qu'on avait on revient
au même cas entre jean luc lemoine et
camille canada exactement la même chose
alors d'un côté baguette a répondu mais
restons pas eu l'air de tortiller du cul
on a débuté en même temps la mouture tpm
paix et sa salle à s'ancrer évidemment
o'kelly je me suis fait une très bonne
amie aussi alors c'est peut-être choisir
chez moi qu'elle est parce que je pense
que j'ai encore une petite chance avec
elle
ah ouais agathe c'est mort quelqu'un a
dit mais elle aussi est en doses et bah
ouais mais tu étais là tout à l'heure
mais la donne elle a quand même la
regarde beau gosse pour l'album non mais
non mais non l on délire aller en délire
et elle induira temps de dire bah ouais
enfin c'est pas su écouter me souvenais
savez que c'est pas vous ouais alors
donc vous préférez clip ça et que c'est
vrai que je préfère pas quelqu'un
c'est le premier de ses 55 ans non je
pense que ça avait arrêté ses 70
secondes pour qu'elle y vit dans ta
gueule
quant à john bim